- Welcome back, everybody.
All hour we've been with the stars
of 80 for Brady, Rita,
Sally, Lily, and Jane.
And today their movie is
"What I'm Loving and Liking."
Now remember, it opens only
in theaters, February 3rd.
It's an amazing film you can
see with your whole family.
I suggest you do that.
Here's another clip.
- What's going on?
- If you're acting very strange, Lou.
- [Lou] Just keep your eyes shut.
- Lou, I've got to get home before dinner.
It's crafts night.
- You got your own house, Maura,
why are you still living
in a retirement center?
- Frank loved it very much.
- Okay, look.
- Ooh, I love presents love
presents. I love presents.
- Woo.
- Oh my gosh,
what is happening?
- I wanted it to be a surprise,
but all they had were gender reveal boxes.
- Who's having a baby?
- No one.
It's not a gender reveal,
it's just a reveal.
- Of what?
- We won the tickets,
we're going to Super Bowl!
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God. How did that happen?
(all cheering)
(audience applauding)
- I'm telling you, you're
gonna love this movie.
I'm liking their posts right
now, everybody. (dings)
And of course,
now is the time I usually give our guests
a $1000 courtesy
of our season long partner
Pilot pen makers of G-2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But since my guests are
the stars of 80 for Brady,
I think that these ladies
are not hurting for cash.
They're fine.
So we're gonna give the money
to a random audience member.
Okay. Everyone look under your seat.
There's a Pilot check under one of them,
taped to the bottom of it.
(drum rolling)
Woo.
(upbeat rock music)
- [Kelly] What's your name?
- My name's Brianna.
- [Kelly] Brianna?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
What are you gonna do
with a $1000?
- I'm gonna pay off my credit card.
(audience cheering)
- Okay. Okay.
Use it to pay off some debt
but use a little bit of it for fun.
- [Brianna] Yes. I agree.
- You only live once.
- I do. You're right.
- I'm not a good influence financially
but this is my suggestion.
Well, it was a great football
and friendship film show, y'all.
Now for our post-game wrap up.
Let's throw it over to
Stephen A. Smith in New York.
Stephen.
- Good afternoon, everybody.
Stephen A. Smith here coming at you
from my K[NO]W MERCY Studios in New York.
It was a well played show on
both sides of the couch today.
Some ladies took shots,
others handed them out.
Fonda might have played her best interview
since her rookie year.
Meanwhile, Clarkson
definitely won the award
for the worst Jerseys choice ever.
The Dallas Cowboys, you
better off cutting a hole
in a used garbage bag than call me, girl.
- Oh my God.
- Come on.
Couldn't have picked a sadder team.
But in the end, everyone played
with heart and that's what matters.
Stay tuned for our
post-game press conference,
immediately following the break.
I'm Stephen A. Smith from
K[NO]W MERCY Studios.
Thanks for watching, everybody.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Whatever.
You're just jealous 'cuz
you're not a Cowboy fan.
That's your problem, Stephen.